People will not stop talking about the NYX
Fat Lip Drip Oil,
and so I had to try it out today.
It was 8 99,
and it is in the shade supermodel.
Is it just like a lip gloss?
Like, I don't know.
Let's test it out.
I usually don't go for super pink shades,
but I thought maybe I'll try it,
and then,
uh.
I don't really love it.
I don't feel like it's worth 8 99.
I just feel like it's kind of sticky,
not super shiny.
Have a two dollar lip gloss that is way shinier
and looks better.
I don't know.
I wanna take it off.
Dang it. I wanted to love it.
I was so excited.
Why do people hype this up?
Am I missing something?
Did I do it wrong?
Um, let me know.
But until. Till I figure it out,
it's a no go for me.